my name is essence Ken and I am the
beauty director at BuzzFeed I was really
inspired by State Farm's 104 good
program where they are challenging their
employees and their agents to complete
100 good beats I've honestly always been
obsessed with pop culture with beauty
with fashion I really wanted to help
expand the narrative of what we perceive
stylish to be what we perceive beauty to
be a time that someone helped me out I
was really just hustling networking I
met this woman her name was Allison and
she's like I'm a writer I write for
different magazines and I was like OMG
can I be your intern I will work for you
for free she was like sure a few weeks
before graduation she calls me and she's
like hey the editor-in-chief at this
magazine I know is looking for an
editorial assistant I recommended you
girl like you are changing my whole
entire life right now that really sold
like a seed of confidence in myself
she also inspired me to pay it forward
in the same way today I'm going to help
pay it forward by helping Makeda who is
trying to find a job in journalism and I
really want to touch on three very
important things confidence-building
interview skills and really dressing to
get the job she wants time to pay it
forward so tell me a little bit about
like what you love about journalism why
you want to get into the industry so I'm
really interested in like the untold
stories especially like minority groups
women's rights I feel like there's so
many people who have a voice but they
don't know how to use it so I would like
to be almost in a way like their
microphone with marketing yourself I
like to think of it in kind of like two
parts right you don't want to just focus
on the professional highlight before
that comes like a physical marketing of
yourself how you interim how you make
eye contact with your interviewer how
you speak about yourself how your energy
is as far as like interviews and first
impressions what's a good move that
can do if I stand out to me the best
first impression is just authenticity
come in with good energy smile what can
I actually wear god I'm still insecure
about certain things and colors and
patterns for the first interview I am
very happy that you brought that up
because we actually have a bunch of cold
wardrobe options for you so we are going
to play dress up right now and try on
some different interview looks okay to
me this is very chic and it's very
feminine I like the length of it I like
my skirts and all that to be longer this
is it one and done a dress is like go to
bed go to I think this is a very good
statement piece so I like the print
because I hear a lot of like ranges of
undershirts underneath yes if a girl I
was interviewing walked in with this I
would be like you know okay for you it's
just a matter of like thinking about
what do I want to feel confident in but
so comfortable in where do you think I
think we should go with the suit I think
so too I'm gonna give you this and these
okay cool Makeda has put on her
interview look why don't you join me you
look so fabulous think yeah what a
reveal this looks so so good how do you
feel in it though I love this look I
love this color I think it's so cute you
just look like a winner like oh my gosh
I've just really feeling this look I
feel extremely ready for an interview I
love this outfit with all your advice I
felt I'm prepared for anything oh my
gosh hug I really found this paying it
forward experience to be extra special I
really hope that this inspired you to
also pay it forward so find out more
ways to give back
visit neighborhood of good calm
[Music]